we are waiting we are watching to get
the first look at the new Royal baby
word is we'll get to see the little baby
tomorrow the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
delivered a son yesterday he was born at
5:26 in the morning local time
weighing in at seven pounds three ounces
Prince Harry shared the good news with
reporters outside Windsor Castle this
little thing is is absolutely stifled so
I'm just over the moon me - Larry CBS
News contributor Tina Brown covered
Harry and Megan's wedding with us and
she's also the author of the Diana
Chronicles Tina good morning - good
morning wasn't he just adorable yes in
that idea he's such a natural trauma I
think so she always comes across as a
human mom you know he's clearly besotted
do you think though in London they're as
excited as we are here in this country
when I landed you know you meet the
passports people I said you know we're
so excited the royal baby's coming are
you as excited as we are from CBS he
goes first I have no idea what CBS is
number one number two no actually not
you know because you know ma'am this is
not the first royal baby well I think
most people in the streets are sight go
ahead well yeah I mean I think Americans
always a little bit more excited to do
okay period right they clap at the
theater and you know it's a little
different I think there is a lot of move
towards this couple definitely and they
announced on Instagram that it's a boys
it's a new way of doing things for this
yes I mean this is really obviously
Instagram is going to be their
communication tool of choice which I
think does give a little bit of
heartburn to the palace traditionalists
because it means it's unmediated you
know they can stick stuff up whenever
they want and they will I do think it's
quite interesting that you know she
actually gave birth at five but they
didn't release it until two in the
nearly 2:00 in the afternoon which means
that they really had an eye across the
pond you know Megan I think is always
gonna be part you know America directed
in in the way she wants the press to
unfold and you know America doesn't get
up until then so that's what he got
released
okay details so Megan Markel she was
past her due date is that right and did
she end up having the baby it brought
more they really wanted to have she
really wanted to have a you know Midwife
birth and we're reflecting she was also
repaired for that she was all for that
but you know
now hearing that she was driven rushed
to the hospital in fact on Sunday night
by Harry and the security detail and she
actually gave birth we're now hearing at
the in Maryland a Maryland hospital and
which is a one actually where Princess
Eugenie the daughter of Fergie Andrew
gave birth so it's actually had royal
births there but maybe in maybe she had
to be induced we don't know yet well it
was definitely a week late so okay you
know what what do we think is gonna
happen with the relationship between the
royal family and the press they've been
hunted by the press when you mentioned
Instagram that's a way also going around
the press what do you think that
relationship will be like I think it's
going to be much more of a kind of
social media driven thing you know Harry
absolutely hates the presses the truth
he regards the press as the people who
killed his mother but at the same time
he's very good with the press he does
know how to charm the press and I think
it's going to be you know a carefully
social media driven very orchestrated
very savvy handling of the press there
just isn't going to be a kind of where
victims of the press they've got it
under control and she's an actress she's
trained she understands about we're
gonna release it this way we're gonna go
across the pond with it we're gonna I
think she's very strict yeah they seem
to be very strategic in the baby being
American and biracial what does that
mean to this royal family well I mean it
is massive I mean look the descendant of
plantation slaves you know is is is
marrying has married the the the one of
the heirs to the throne he's far down
the list but he's nonetheless an heir to
the throne it is still a huge thing I
think it's a huge thing frankly for the
British public because actually
interracial children are now the
fastest-growing minority group and
there's a lot of delight I think for
women who are married at you know who
are in interracial marriages to say you
know they have experiences where people
say is that your baby they say they're
very proud I'm happy yeah but that is
now what gonna happen because you know
we it's 2019 it's 2019 yeah
modern marriage yeah Thank You Tina like
always good to have you here yeah always
good to have here